all right we're back
welcome back to beautiful Myrtle Beach
we're in South Carolina we are joined by
Senator and 2024 Republican presidential
candidate Senator Tim Scott you
mentioned your mom before you came out I
I had met your mom on a previous
occasion and uh what a wonderful woman
she is she reminds me of my mom
absolutely she worked 16 hours a day you
know my mom worked 16 hours a day you
know going back a little bit to what we
played with Obama and joy joyless I call
her Behar
um and your background
you nearly flunked out in the ninth
grade yeah cool but then you finished
College you did really well and you ran
into an owner of a Chick-fil-A that
mentored you John Moniz yes and then
your godfather your grandfather dropped
out of school to pick cotton in third
grade yes and then he couldn't read but
he would sit at the table every day and
read as if he was reading to be a good
example and you say from cotton to
Congress in one generation is a journey
that can only happen in America
which I thought was a beautiful line
and your grandfather faced real
discrimination if there was a white
person walking down the street you told
the story how he would step aside
absolutely yeah I mean 1921 my
grandfather was born here in South
Carolina Southeast South Carolina
and it was a very different South
Carolina
it was a place where a black guy walking
down the street would have to get off
the sidewalk and let someone walk by who
was white it was such a different and
challenging time
my grandfather when my parents divorced
we moved into his house when I was seven
years old my grandfather looked at me
and said
the weight of his words were so heavy
because of all that he had experienced
in his life he said you can be bitter
or you can get better
but you can't be both
and
when I hear people telling me that
America is a racist Nation I gotta say
not my America not our America not be
United States of America
and I say that
and I say that because I've watched the
evolution in my own family I remember
the stories my grandfather told me he
believed then with some doubt now in the
goodness of this nation and it's that
conviction that led me to understand if
you work hard
you have integrity and you have Grit
all things are possible in today's
America and the left
and the left
we all know this to be true
the left
the left weaponizes race
whatever they're losing an argument
that does my grandfather a dis Justice
an injustice is disrespectful the pain
and the progress of this nation should
be viewed as a symbol or or a logical
understanding of what's possible in the
windshield of Life yeah think about this
John and I'll I'll I'll move on to
something else but I'm the guy that ran
for congress in 2010.
in Charleston South Carolina
where the Civil War started
my primary opponent was the son of Strom
Thurmond
think about that
let us pray
[Applause]
oh by the way we should kneel in prayer
not in protest that's
so
said
[Applause]
in that race I won 68-32
because of the evolution of the Southern
heart we started judging people by the
content of our character not the color
of our skin
and the left
and the left they refused to deal with
America in 2023 and not 1923 because
they know that the truth of my life
disproves the lies of their radical
agenda they don't want to educate our
kids they want to indoctrinate our kids
they don't want to teach American
history
we have a responsibility to pass this
nation On to the Next Generation
healthy
whole and looking in the windshield of
life not the rearview mirror and I
refuse to stay on the sidelines and let
my America
become a victim of the radical wealth
let's I have I started in radio believe
it or not in 1987. okay yeah I know well
so don't don't even try
um I've been on Fox since 1996 and I've
been blessed and thanks to all of you
you made this up my dreams possible
thank you thank you all
and I will tell you I've never been this
worried about our country than I am
right now yes I'm worried about our
economy we have two-thirds of our fellow
Americans live in paycheck to paychecks
uh I worry about the high price of
everything a 40-year high of inflation
yes I worry about open borders I worry
about crime in our big cities and small
towns I I worry about America giving up
its energy Independence and and we're
now importing oil from countries that
hate our guts like Venezuela and OPEC
nations unbelievable I'm worried about
China Russia Iran and a new axis of Evil
I got a lot of things I'm worried about
yes let's talk about some of those
issues but I think you started off right
where when I think about when we were in
the majority we passed tax reform I have
the Good Fortune of writing the domestic
side of our tax reform tcga the tax cuts
and job act that we said we passed in
2017. we cut the taxes of a single
mother like the one that raised me by 70
percent that's Republicans did for dual
for dual income households we cut taxes
for dual income households by 60 percent
we said we'd give back to the American
people four thousand dollars on average
we gave back forty four hundred dollars
but what we also did was we had high
employment low inflation because the
government did not print and spend money
we gave it back to the American people
because we believed in we the people
give you your money back let you live
your lives and things get better it is
there we've got to do that again is
there a way to restrain government
spending because every time absolutely
so controlling government spending is
what I said earlier please please please
fire Joe Biden that's the first thing
you have to do
and here's the second thing
you have to understand and we all
understand it because we're living at 49
of Americans or so median income in this
country is 1750 or 35
000 a year because of Joe Biden's
inflation the average monthly expenses
have increased by
five hundred dollars almost
that's not a problem that's a crisis for
people on fixed incomes and single moms
that raised me and the reason why this
happened is because they printed and
then spent four trillion dollars the way
we say it in the South just turn to
spigot off
don't spend what you don't have let me
ask you don't print what you don't need
and don't buy itself you can't afford
that's called South Carolina
that's just how we do it
so you live within your means I always
like Connie Mack had the Penny Plan we
probably needed a nickel plant at this
point so we're going to cut government
spending lower Government taxes uh and
then we've got issues I think energy
Independence would go a long way
towards lowering family costs on
everything and creating six-figure jobs
absolutely when we cut taxes by the way
Revenue to the government went up by
three percent the first year three
percent the second year so if you lower
taxes revenues to the government goes up
because everything's on sale but we have
to understand as a nation we the people
understand it President Biden and the
radical left they do not energy
Independence is National Security
they're one and the same we must be let
me ask you independent we were
independent we were and then they gave
it here's here's where I see America
right now it's like we're split in half
I mean either do you believe and defund
dismantle the police and no bail laws
who you believe in Law and Order how do
you reconcile that you believe in
securing our Borders or you want open
borders you believe in energy
Independence so you buy into this you
know climate alarmist religious cult uh
you either believe America should be the
most powerful Nation on Earth with the
baddest military to defend us evil yes
or amen yes and amen or they want to or
they want to cut this down but we've got
a party that is the Democratic party
today in no way resembles the Democratic
party of old without any question we
have to persuade people to join our team
here's what I can tell you
I've done the surveys I've run around
the country
African-Americans around 81 percent want
the same level of policing or more
policing not less that's a lie from the
radical left we have to understand that
most of America wants the same thing how
many all in here believe in Law and
Order
[Applause]
how many y'all
are thanking God Almighty and willing to
stand with me and back the blue
this is common sense
you see when I wrote a bill to help
refund the police because the crazy left
defunded the police they called me a
token
because they are opposed to helping the
very people they say they care about the
most
how many all believe that we should
secure our Southern border today
[Music]
today
not tomorrow but today
every yes we all believe this we all
know this to be true
we
is is not
it happens it's not this is what I was
taught
if you don't control your back door at
your house
it's not your house
if you don't control your Southern
border it might not be our country
every County in America is a border
County
seventy thousand Americans have lost
their lives to Fentanyl
seventy thousand
the precursors come from China they're
made in manufacturing locations in
Mexico and then the Mexican cartels
bring it across our Southern borders and
our ports of Entry president Scott not
on my watch we're gonna stop that from
happening without any questions we will
freeze their assets
and unleash the most powerful force on
this Earth to protect Americans gotta
take a break more with Senator Scott
you'll take questions from our audience
as we continue alive in beautiful Myrtle
Beach South Carolina your questions here
for the senator when we come back hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else